the night shift follows the staff of
those who work the late shift in the
emergency room at San Antonio Memorial
Hospital the Rich Eisen show is a proud
proud member of a radio affiliate in San
Antonio as well we're listened to every
single day in that wonderful city of San
Antonio Scott wolf joining us here from
the night shift on NBC good to see you
brother please continue to so I'm sorry
I trashed your Mets you'd be way out
here but if Bryce Harper is going to say
I want to go to New York because of Mets
fans and the Yankees don't get a shot at
him because of Mets fans I have to say
something about it yeah I don't mind you
you got to say whatever you can to get
mr. Harper in your uniform but riffraff
come on now
all right come on now you are not when
when I've been dive but first game I
ever went to yeah in my life yeah Shea
Stadium was it it was I was a I was on
up the left-field line yeah um and I
remember John Milner was warming up to
play left-field for the Mets that know
when mickey lowlich was the starting
pitcher I'll go back back nine of his
career what's crazy so when we and we we
had we hash this out last time I was
here but when we first got to New Jersey
this my my step that at the time was a
big Yankee spend so we went to I was a
Yankee fan before I was a Mets fan and I
know what in the hell I played baseball
in high school and a bunch of my buddies
were all Mets fans and it just at we
[ __ ] we went to more Met games at that
time than what there was the same are we
the same age close so it this was I
graduated in 86
so none who's in high school or college
um what happened to the Mets in 86 okay
I did I just got oh sorry yeah ah so
we're we did hash this out the like I
said we did we did we went there but
funny story so my wife once she and I
met we're living in New York City does
and she was not a huge sports fan and it
was kind of meaningful to me as a huge
sports fan to try and you know bring her
in a little bit so I take her to a game
at Yankee Stadium and the game starts
and I said honey say we were engaged at
the time we were like we were there
dating or just engaged I said if you've
got any questions I wanted to make it as
good an experience for as possible any
questions about anything she said great
so top of the first no questions bottom
of the first I think there's like a hit
and someone steals a base and she's like
I have a question okay awesome what is
it and she points to the upper deck this
is the old Yankee saving old in stage
okay and she goes you see that railing
way up there do you think anyone's ever
fallen off that okay that was her
question not it's not deep in the
rulebook hello or anything it's not like
any trivia no not any trivia and my yeah
my yeah this is her what was your answer
ah probably if it was che definite but
so she's since kind of chill watch them
chill she'll watch some golf and our
kids are starting to play sports now so
she's good
opening up to it up have you been in the
new Citi Field the Mets uh yeah I've
heard nothing but great things about
I've never been yeah beautiful beautiful
do they do they still have the Apple
that comes out of every home run yeah I
haven't been I haven't been enough of
this year I will never forget and I have
a story about my wife and a stadium in
Shea Stadium
yeah I met my wife at the newsroom of
ESPN many many many moons ago yeah when
I looked at when I had the same hair as
you did yeah or do you do now at anyway
like I just got to get over the fact
that you don't age I'm sorry say it
again please that fact that it's strange
I'm looking at a photo someone posted
from 1997 you look better now it's it's
crazy
like right in the heart of party of five
like right in the middle of it at once
on the wall the elevators at Fox I'm
gonna party five big poster what do you
mean
Scott's pictures every time I go in and
out of Fox Sports they have a big part
are UFOs yeah everywhere over the years
that that that photo has migrated it was
probably it was like in the executive
wing and now to the men's room where is
it it's like a picture day when you come
in the others on the first floor of the
Fox hey that seems like a big spot
that's both listen he's not finishing
his sentences to be more accurate as to
where it is but at least he's saying
it's on the first floor of [ __ ] yeah
it's building Fox Sports odd Fox is -
now is it the big fox or the little
fuzzy sweater is it big hug big fox
twentieth century fox lot days long it's
not in like a dumpster by
I don't think so come on now is there by
the way is there ever been any any party
of five reunion ether that's outside
yeah and yellow together again and see
what's going on everybody asks and and
that shows not sort of ripe to reboot
like some of these other shows then you
know the basic premise of the thing was
their parents unfortunately died and
would they survive as a family and then
they survived as a family and so I don't
think anybody feels like digging that
back up is a good idea but you sure
about that
make it like party of 30 right everybody
comes back together for a reunion I
hadn't thought about that like
everyone's got families of their own and
we shoot it maybe like in Maui if that's
where you would like to shoot it yeah
anyone who's listening if there's party
of five party of thirty yeah Aloha how
do you thirty about when you take that
picture yes go and take that idea
directly into Dana Walden's office later
today Fox yeah who's in charge of the
whole operation can you get in there yes
here's a funny story I did at so a buddy
of mine was given one of those giant
they so they had faces from all the cast
members just and when I tell you it was
like eight feet by eight feet and so it
was given to a buddy of mine from
someone who worked at Fox one of them
maybe there's one still hanging up there
and he had it like in his garage for a
minute it was like scaring the children
and I said let me I said would you let
me have it and it's just like a social
experiment I had a bunch of people over
for dinner
we had a dinner party at a new house my
wife and I were living in and I hung it
on the dining room wall and I didn't say
word one about it and I I just wanted to
see what would happen if people thought
that I was that guy just and I had a
jart literally a full wall sized picture
of my own face and so we're eating
dinner and no one's saying anything it
was the greatest thing and at the end of
dinner I was like all right I said to
let you guys in on a little something I
was like you've all been kind of part of
a little bit of a social experiment and
I was like this is usually not here and
they were like oh he could oh yeah
because they were was like one guy yeah
we should get you a picture of like you
is that what the sin
to her right that didn't a rod used to
have a picture of myself as a centaur in
his house yeah we can do that here yeah
how do we know this weeks it was part of
an article yes MA yeah the photograph of
it Scott wolf pardon my ignorance is
Center is like a half-man half-animal ie
rods torso and face and then the body of
an animal well now you know what to get
me for Christmas this Scott wolf sent to
the night shift on NBC but the story I
was telling is it yes you know I met
many many many moons ago at ESPN and she
was a producer I was going to be on the
air and I was doing a piece with the big
three of the Atlanta Braves Glavine
Smoltz Maddux yeah and Bobby Cox is the
manager and we went down to Shea to
interview all four of them yeah and she
was a producer I was going to be you
know the the reporter yeah and we get to
Shea and the locker room that we were
going to use could not be used because
it was Todd Hundley's farewell press
conference remember Tata yeah okay that
was in the old Jets locker room where
we're going to use so they've said let's
you can interview them outside and I'm
like well wait a minute
every plane that comes into LaGuardia is
going to zoom over ahead like John
Smoltz is going to say the most profound
thing and what won't hear it over the
engine roar so what they said we'll find
you another spot and the spot they found
us was this room in Shea Stadium in the
bowels of Shea Stadium that had to sign
glaucoma testing on the door we opened
it up it stunk so bad Suzy found a can
of some sort of Glade and an oscillating
fan that we sprayed in the room and it
stunk such to high heaven because the
cat of Shea Stadium lived in there
that's Shea Stadium in a nutshell so
this is so for future Hall of Famers
were coming into that room to have you
in every single time that we sat down
there go like what the hell stink so bad
they might have but some it was a hell
of a piece though yeah yeah those are
the grin little gays yes the clutter it
servi taste of Shea Stadium which is now
may it may it now rest in peace how do
you like doing the night shift brother I
love to it I love it I have to say you
know fourth season is something they
don't give you easily no more
ridiculously great cast and crew a
really cool show you know it's a really
good Hospital show man
it's really intense this you know the
episode that airing tonight is really
incredible my character was a guy who
was like super you know kind of god
complex II rigid controlled who over the
past couple seasons has gotten a little
way more vulnerable and had layers of
him peeled away this year he's kind of
trying to get back to that place where
he feels in supreme control and in
tonight's episode he gets an opportunity
that clip we showed is a little bit of
it he gets an opportunity and this
awakening to to kind of recapture how he
used to feel as a doctor and and be the
person that he knows he's supposed to be
it's fantastic
Congrats on a fourth season and then
that's a 10 Eastern and nine San Antonio
time tonight stuff that's where it takes
place
yeah and so is uh Gregg Popovich or any
of the Spurs Kawhi Leonard gonna make us
good guest our appearance on I should
wait they'd have to yet they'd have to
you know meet some horrible fate so we
not we can't have that
yeah unless they were there as like one
of those you know visits with the person
who got hurt yeah I should pick up their
spirit or it's just a guest star
appearance that you're in the you're in
the you're in the operating room yes I'm
sort mask comes down and it's Gregg
Popovich yeah we did have um I'm remiss
to like I'm forgetting his name now but
we had so we've had a couple of amazing
MMA fighters because there's a
ridiculously great training center down
there in that we actually shoot in New
Mexico okay Albuquerque New Mexico and
there's this really great MMA fighting
center down there and some of them one
of the characters on our show is an MMA
fighter played by Brendan Fehr is a
doctor who does uh mixed martial arts
neat hobby it's not the way it's a hell
of a hobby a hobby huh
we cannot I'm excited about this fight
coming up okay John do uh what do you
think I think McGregor has one puncher's
chance I don't know if he's going to be
able to get that channel and some to
heal and something heal and something I
would be phenomenal but his face is
going to get touched a bunch problem I
don't know
I mean Mayweather doesn't
Julie beat people up I mean that was a
funny very in the press conference he
threatened to knock him out and McGregor
says you haven't knocked anyone out in
20 years I heard that is there any like
it's pretty clear that it can't be any
like you can't grab he can't kick him he
can't grab him well um correct
he cannot kick him it is a boxing yes
right but he's going to clench and he's
going to do everything to get his head
on his head and knock him around best he
can yeah with whatever he can do but
Mayweather has been known for being such
a tactician you had to use that phrase
when you talk about the sweet science
Cindy um that he doesn't allow people
anywhere near his kitchen every that's
why you're saying yeah if it could be if
the ring with Taft is big would it be
great
it sounds great yeah half court
basketball during the day
yeah half court boxing at night so it's
just going to be it's just going to
Gregor just stalking in the hole yeah
but it is going to be an absolute circus
that I might want to just personally
oddball just to see what that pose for
sure don't you think
yeah I'd love it I'm excited to see you
Scott wolf it's always great to come
back anytime you're a great man that's
what I haven't likewise likewise the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked that video be sure
to download our apps don't have any
memory on your phone let's start to
delete some of those slow-mo videos you
have and you know which ones I'm talking
about